hey guys what's up this is andrew from
transitions.com
so i'm finally back to my place guys i
feel so good i feel so great
i have my gears my microphone that i
miss so much
i have my bookcase i have all my
computers i'm ready to work hard guys
and and today i want to make a big
analysis guys on amc
we are looking good to me there is a lot
of information i want to
show you guys so let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so as usual right now as
i'm doing daily updates guys on amc i'm
gonna start on the 15 minutes time frame
i'm going to start by reminding you
what i was saying in my previous video
so basically i was
showing you guys this breakout area so
we have here
a medium term breakout of this trend
that for me was the bullish signal i
gave you guys
i told you many times not too formal
here that we're gonna have a pullback in
this area
37 35 were very nice levels to buy i
gave you those as well on my discord
guys
so here we have the typical excess
that happens you know in this kind of
situation just like we had you know in
this breakout as i showed you guys
before
uh the breakout that occurred in may
just before the strong move up strong
rally so i'm not saying we're gonna have
the same rally guys
but i'm just saying that here we had the
same situation with some excesses
below the trend line so we are in the
same situation
i was calling for strong move up this
monday and this
is what happened guys so here we are
looking exactly
as we should the reason why i was that
bullish this monday
and i posted that on my discord as well
guys is because here i have
a shorter term breakout associated with
the divergence all right so this is the
technique i like to use
so we have it on the longer term as well
here we have the divergence
on the 15 minutes time frame so you see
macd
going higher so the momentum is
reverting and the market making
lower lows so basically in this
situation it means the market is out of
steam and here we have the same
situation on the shorter term so
basically this trade is the same as this
one
just smaller so we're going to have the
same pattern guys this is fractals all
right
we have the same fractals repeating on
different time degrees
and here so we had this breakout this
retest
and then we went higher so i was trying
to guide you guys
on my discord on the daily price action
and i was telling you that what i like
to use is the 50 the five minutes time
frame guys so to spot divergences to
know when the move up will be finished
and here you can see that technically we
had a very little one alright so here
the macd is making
lower lows lower highs sorry and the
market is making a higher high all right
so here technically we have a very small
divergence
that gave us a very small move but
basically that you would have the
divergence here so it was kind of too
late to act
but to me this divergence is not clean
enough right now we are looking good
because we are consolidating guys we are
making a
lower highs with the macd going lower so
this is good guys we go lower this is a
typical
consolidation correction in the strong
move up so here
my guess would be that so we we are
moving in five waves
as we did here guys it's very important
to know if you move in five waves or in
three ways
it's going to give you a strong
information about the direction of the
trend
and here you can see that moves up are
developing in five waves
so i'm not sure i put three here here
one two
three three four five all right
and here it's exactly the same as a
label already let me put it in yellow
and you're gonna ask me yeah but look
it looks like the corrective wave is
developing in five waves too
right so what's the issue guys here
what's the issue for those who have
watched the training that i put online
for free guys
about elliott wave theory you should be
able to tell me what is wrong
here guys what is wrong in this counting
okay
the third is the shortest so this is not
a valid counting so this is not five
waves down
it's an abc guys
it can only be an abc we do not have
five waves here
so we have a b c and the c wave is just
deeper than the wave a which is totally
fine so this is my counting and here it
looks like a one
two the third looks complete so the
question is where is going to fifths
so the fifths might go to the 41.8 and
then we correct
maybe or the fifth may go here so to
know that
you use fib extensions you measure the
length of the one plus three
and you apply to the bottom of the
fourth and the usual levels are
61.8 one or 1.618
so in this situation the 48th level
would make sense for me and extended
fifths
this would make sense the 42 level could
make sense as well
so let's see let's see we need to
analyze the daily price action to have
more information from here guys
you know i could give you a guess but it
would only be a guess
i would have no solid proof
of what i'm saying so i prefer to just
tell you that during the day
i'm gonna give you more information
looking for those kind of
patterns like small short-term
divergences one more information that is
interesting is to see how much we
retraced
of this abc for now we did 50
this was by the way the high of the day
40.5 i didn't have this
as a resistance level but it was the
just 50
retracement of the abc that was going
lower so basically there is one
rule that is saying that as long as we
stay below the 50 percent we are bearish
whenever we move higher we are bullish
right simple rule so here for now we are
still below
so i would like to see a daily close
above this level
and of course i would like to see a
daily close above the 41.8 which will
open the gate
finally to the 50 level that would be
very interesting to
watch so guys that's it for me i will
keep it short i will give you more
information on my discord i will try to
update you on the amc and gme
daily press action during the day and i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did guys please don't forget to click on
the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new so stay close to shore i'll see you
guys